at the basic level the human brain wants
to build relationships we are social in
nature we cannot thrive without that
bonding we needed to a family to a tribe
to a clan and in fact now we live in a
in a global world in which you can
create these bonds all over the place
what seems to happen is that there are
forces of fear that then drive people to
activate and look on how to destroy
rather than to build something there's
so many stories of people who at a
personal level for example one of the
great stories is a little grandmother
who wakes up in the middle of the night
with a man standing over her bed with
the club ready to kill her rather than
engage in an aggressive act she simply
looks up with an open heart and says you
must be hungry let me make you some soup
you must be cold let me take you into
another room where we have heat the man
doesn't hit her she says to the
granddaughter who's in bed with her it's
ok honey lay down and go to sleep she's
a secure base and they walk into the
kitchen they have soup and now it's 2
o'clock in the morning and he goes back
or she goes back to bed and goes to
sleep saying let me make a bed for you
behind the stove he goes to sleep the
next morning the police arrived with a
k-9 unit he was a murderer who had
escaped from prison but even more
shocking just two miles before coming to
her house
he had brutally slaughtered with a club
a family of four now she created so much
bonding so much money he could not kill
her and this is a basic fundamental
truth people cannot kill people and you
say but every day you read in the paper
people kill people
they're killing objects they're killing
things there's a deep personalization
that has to happen in the mind's eye it
is the demonization it's the enemy
making process that then drives that
ability to kill now we can train we can
train the military we can train police
I've been a hostage negotiator and
police psychologist for 35 years we and
some people have to do that you are a
police officer you may have to act to
kill another human being for the right
reasons and at that moment though
there's a price to be paid because if
you truly see that person as a person
you could not do it
of course this bonding can get out of
control with what is known as the
Stockholm Syndrome as well where the
bond between a hostage and a hostage
taker gets so strong that when the
police come in the hostage will defend
the hostage takers and this happens in
organizations all the time where people
are taken hostage by too strong a bond
because of personal relationships
because they don't want to hurt people
they're not able to get a boundary
between the social bonding too much
harmony teams that have too much harmony
they're not going to be as effective as
those that have good disagreements good
conflicts get issues out in the open
you'll hear the great leaders always
speak about you must get the fish on the
table go through the bloody mess of
cleaning it for the great fish dinner at
the end of the day that's how you build
a high-performing team if you're
avoiding conflict if you tend not to be
willing to engage in these dialogues
with difference around difference here
the difference you don't get that
greater truth and that's really the
heart of